[Music]
no I was reading this group chat you
want to see what it was lose your mind
no no a different group chat yeah it was
pretty crazy trying to want to show you
probably in trouble rob gronkowski the
Patriots tight end back to his
fun-loving ways a little bit he still
seems a little muted Tom Curren of NBC
Sports Boston never muted when he joins
us Tom good morning how are you buddy
Michael how are you good I'll be doing
better too after I get some information
from you about where the Patriots
currently are physically mentally
emotionally let's start with Gronk we
just played his clip from yesterday's
press conference and the narrative on
him all year long is there something
that's not right with Grogg he's not as
happy as he used to be he's not as
joyful as he used to be he's not as good
as he used to be you are much closer to
this than we are what has been your take
on where Gronk is now and why it seems
he isn't the same guy that he's been
throughout his career the fact that he
had his impasse with the team over the
summer actually spring and the fact that
that led to them dangling him to the
Detroit Lions I think hurt him he's a
sensitive kid he's always been kind of a
I'll do whatever the coaches tell me he
he stays within the lines even though he
Axl you know it goes rogue a little bit
he stays within the lines of what the
coaches want so the fact that he and Tom
Brady I think under Brady's auspices
Brady said you know what you need to
exercise some of your own autonomy here
as an individual you're your own
business you need to take care of your
body the way you do in the best way for
you at this point in your career you've
been hurt so often so he did that in
2017 he got a lot of pushback from the
team by the end of the year in the
offseason he and Brady kind of did their
own thing and then when the Patriots
you know what we're kind of sick of this
you're making too much money we think
you're gonna start to decline we're
going to try to trade to the Detroit
that hurt him and when he got injured
the beginning of the season and slowed
down and his production dipped it got in
his head okay they didn't give me a
raise they tried to trade me now I'm
hurting I'm not going to hit any of my
incentives do I really like football
cause last year I couldn't stand
football because of the head coach so
that was a lot of wicked into his head I
was convinced that if they had won Super
Bowl 52 against the Eagles Rob
Gronkowski was gonna walk off into the
sunset and the fact that they lost the
game ultimately fueled his decision to
come back for one more year do you
believe he would have walked if they'd
won last year and do you think he walks
away win or lose this year I do think
that he will retire this year I'm not
the retirement will stick but I do think
that he would take a year off football
at the very least and because he has
gone through a ridiculously arduous
process since about 2009 with his body
and I don't think it's gotten any easier
this year there was a game against Miami
when he started to play well there were
about three different kill shots on him
in the course of that game that were
just brutal hits by TJ McDonald and I
think he has to look at it say it's it's
not it's not worth it physically to do
it for half of what some players who are
as less productive than I am do it so I
think he wouldn't walk away part of what
was googling in Minneapolis last year
the week before the Super Bowl Tom was
this notion that the family has been
wearing him out to get away from
football he doesn't need the money he
can make more money or at least make
good money just being wrong whether he
he becomes an actor whether he just
becomes a part of guy who pops up from
time to time whether they just do Gronk
cruises one after the other and that the
family was concerned about his
concussions for all the other injuries
and he's had the broken arm and he's had
staph infections and ACL tears and back
surgeries but
it's the concussions that concern the
family and my understanding is had been
a lot of pressure on him from his family
as there should be to say hey you don't
need this anymore and I feel like at
times this year that that attitude has
emanated from him I don't I'm getting
too old for this I feel like that is
what his coming from him even though he
hasn't said it I can sense it
you're on two percent correct his family
has been because there are four
individuals who played in the NFL and
the dad is you know has been
athletically inclined and very involved
in everything that Gronk has done it has
a great understanding of look your
channel when you're in the NFL you are
going to be used up and then spit out
the other side do what's best for you
and that's why you know they would
release joint statements when Gronk was
hurt that's why I grant you know said in
2015 I'll come back when I'm 100 percent
from a knee situation there's very I've
always called a Gronk Inc they've the
Patriots has to deal to Gronk Inc and he
is a product and I don't think I don't
want to that the sound in a callous way
that the family takes advantage of him
because they don't they love him very
much because I think they do believe he
needs that level of shepherding but he's
also a pleaser
he's a pleaser with Belichick he's a
pleaser with his family and at
approaching 30 I think that he doesn't
know exactly what he ought to do and a
lot of people have a lot of advice for
him
whether it's Brady whether it's the team
whether it's his family whether it's
true rosenhouse but in the end he's
playing for less money than other
players of his ilk have played for he's
taking ridiculous punishment there are
days when he doesn't like going to work
so there comes a point where he's like
you know do I want to keep doing this
but I think that the success of the team
down the stretch here he got his brain
finally with a lot of effort to kind of
a let's stay in the moment kind of
situation and there were times this year
where he just looked like he was washed
up and it looked at times like Tom Brady
was washed up and I've got a theory and
I think the pay
traits may have inadvertently stumbled
on to an injury report loophole because
if you've got guys who have their own
training staff if you've got Tom Brady
and Rob Gronkowski going to see Alex
Guerrero and they never tell you they're
injured whatever the extent of the
injury is whatever the injury may be and
I know there was a lot of thought that
Tom Brady had an MCL strain in his knee
this year that was never reported if oh
but it wasn't reported on the injury
report was it yeah weeks
okay never forget that then okay never
mind
a lot of things under wraps if you if
you have a side trainer who is handling
your situation and it never comes you
know it never becomes a big deal within
the confines of what the team is dealing
with I don't know I don't necessarily
agree with you because I do think that
part of the Alex Guerrero Patriots
relationship and again I think I've told
you this before I mean the Patriots
refer people to Guerrero have do and
will continue to because there has been
a good relationship he's a soft tissue
genius the nutrition stuff sometimes I
think it runs a fire field of what you
know the folks within the team will take
care of nutrition would want to do
certainly the resistance bands instead
of free weights is something that runs a
foul of what you know Moses Cabrera
would necessarily say but they do try to
be complimentary and part of that I
think this year is they tried to
reconstruct the relationship that
bubbled over a little bit last year was
to make sure that everything is
symbiotic okay if if we're doing
something here we need to know so that
we can work well together as we have in
the past why is there a sense that
everyone is against the Patriots why is
there though I mean I guess there is to
a certain level an animosity toward the
Patriots as there would be toward any
successful football team but it feels a
little over the top
it feels like they really have created
this sense that no one believes in us
that that it's us against the world
it worked against the Chiefs of course
they were underdogs against the Chiefs
where does this come from is this just
basic good old-fashioned motivational
tactics that may or may not be rooted in
reality how do they pull this idea off
that no one believes in them when it's
clear that everyone does well it's clear
now that everyone does what was the
conversation after they lost the
Pittsburgh and didn't manage a touchdown
what was the conversation asked today
and that's in the very recent past what
was the conversation after they paid
down their leg at halftime in Miami and
then met up a touchdown and had allow
almost 200 yards rushing
those were games that happened down the
stretch those were weeks 13 and 14 and
then weeks 15 and 16 against the bills
and yet people dismissed it out of hand
the interesting thing about the success
of all the sports teams here in New
England in Boston is that there's very
much a nitpicking mentality that goes on
because it's hard to continue to
celebrate the team's
year in and year out as being especially
the Patriots
everything's great thirteen and three
fourteen and two Super Bowl appearance
so in order to churn the water we have
conversations about when's it going to
end and I'm part of that and also
there's a lot of conversations about
Belichick socks or Brady sucks or
Guerrero sucks or Gronk sucks or
Patricia was horrible
so that drum beat is very very real here
so it isn't very hard to them to in 20
18 and 19 find Instagram comments
Twitter comments
talk radio television your stuff where
my seasoned flesh your your website
which only you know might occasionally
point out that you know where they come
out you know didn't play well flat
didn't play well well what's wrong with
the Patriots or what's wrong with crunk
so I think if you're looking for
motivation and whenever this team has
found motivation like 2016 was about
vindication you know 2014 was about
validating what they did a decade
earlier
all those ones in the in the to early
two-thousands were about establishing a
dynasty so to speak when they had
something to play for they play better
well they've got one more game to play
this year and they're going for their
six the Super Bowl championship Tom I
got a lot more can get to with you let
me let me try one more thing here we cuz
we discussed this recently on your show
when you look at everything the Patriots
have accomplished over the last 17 years
nine Super Bowl appearances great
regular-season records number one seeds
eight straight AFC championship games
isn't it a disappointment that the
Patriots are only five and three in the
Super Bowl
I think that insane just they have a 600
winning percentage against the best team
from the other conference five and three
sixty percent of the time you win
additionally what's the nature of those
three losses in one of them the first
one Tom Brady took his team down threw a
touchdown pass to Randy Moss and then
the Giants went the other way and scored
on an incredible drive that had some
fascinating plays a touchdown to win in
2011 that team was horrible had no
business being in the Super Bowl but got
there in part because of a Billy Cundiff
missed field goal and the fact that they
were just a smart team and I don't care
that they went whatever 14 and to 1303
asteroid male he said we weren't good
enough
they still practically won that game had
Wes Welker come up with a catch and then
obviously we know what happened last
year so the five and three is the five
and three but it's pretty close to an
eight no we could also say there could
be two and six but when you look at the
five and three in my estimation it could
be eight no very very easily alright Tom
I gotta let you go and you know my
theory I think Belichick I think Bella
check this time around is gonna try to
drop the head early and deliver the
knockout punch by halftime so it's not
close in the fourth quarter and I have a
feeling he can pull it off alright Tom
see how Atlanta buddy thanks alright
there is Tom Curren NBC Sports Boston
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports